[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time I'm red and I'm
gonna give you something out of my
throat oh gotta be able to talk first
link oh hey link this week at the round
table of dim lighting we are reminiscing
about
the good old days when times were bad
before the internet
what was it like to live before the
internet well we can tell you because we
were there for it so pull up a chair and
we're also
there for the part that was after this
we're still here we're still here we're
still we're still in it and the
internet's still happening every single
generation and every single person
likes to sort of Center all of time
around themselves this is a very natural
thing to do that's why everyone always
thinks that the world is ending when
they're alive everyone if you're many
Christians and when we were well they
centered time around no Jesus right but
not themselves uh yeah but when Jesus is
going to come back like you remember you
remember what it was like to feel like
you were like I really think Jesus is
going to come back in my lifetime it's
just we all like to think that right
so take this with a grain of salt but I
do feel like there's a significance to
how old we are specifically as it
relates to the internet which is
obviously one of the hugest most
influential technological shifts that's
ever happened and that is that we got a
childhood
that was completely internet free
internet free with the exception of a
few like we were exposed to the internet
in like very very metered doses at some
rich kids house when we were like 16 or
17.
but in terms of the internet being a
part of our Lives it's called Trent
summary kid he was more than some rich
kid he was he was a special friend he
was great but in the context of that uh
point he was just some rich kid as you
would I mean he had a couch in his
bedroom yeah you know I mean if you got
a bedroom with a couch in it that's
pretty amazing his bedroom you've got a
computer with the internet in it
translation that really it was bigger
than not only bigger than my parents
bedroom it was bigger than my living
room
Trent's bedroom was bigger than every
house in the McLaughlin household I mean
In fairness his dad was a builder you
know I would expect no less
right you can build yourself a house
give the kids big rooms I was like this
house has two staircase it's just more
roof you know I mean we were so wowed by
this guy's Trent we're getting off on a
little Trent uh sidebar here no this is
this is very pertinent but I haven't
landed my point yet for a boy that was
wowed by a couch and two different
staircases
there's two ways under the second floor
in this guy's house well it could have a
fire you could go up one way and come
down another way
you can have like the
and like a foot race on multiple levels
and then there would be in each
staircase could be one way
did if our minds are so blown by that
think about what the internet did you
think that Trent went up one staircase
and then came down the other one yeah
was it down and up but you know how
when you have to walk someplace like
maybe it's someplace in your
neighborhood not since the internet uh
and you walk there one way and you walk
back a different way because you feel I
love that it's shorter
there's multiple times that I've
realized why do I come back this way why
don't I come back the same exact way
that I came if I thought that that was
the shortest way well I mean what is
that when you're in a it's no I'm
talking about walking it's it's oh
you're talking just about walking that's
what I started what is that walking well
the answer to your question is
um stimulus man what I'm asking really
in the context of that rich kid Trent
some rich kid is did he did he suffer
from that same thing and do you think
that he came out one staircase because
he thought that was the best way
upstairs but going down was the better
way to go downstairs and do you think
that that's why his dad put two
staircases into his house because he
knew that Trent needed to have options
and the other other son
thank you I don't think that was the
reason yeah but we we had you know do we
have something to offer on this subject
well we definitely have them I have to
finish the second part about it yeah so
finish it
um you know I'm just waiting we are the
only generation
that had a childhood completely internet
free and then adulthood that was
basically while we were in college the
internet became a thing that was going
to be in everyone's life while we were
in college like while we were going from
right childhood to adulthood that change
and that's just an unusual thing that
like put a feather in our in our 45 year
old caps yeah because we can say that
about ourselves not everybody can say
that link
so we do have a unique perspective on
this
that's what I was going to do and we're
going to give it to you I think one of
the reasons this is so fresh in our
minds is because
we just released a video over on the
Rhett and Link channel this is the third
video
that we've released once we started
putting videos out over there just you
know keeping you guessing expressing
ourselves creatively
give it a give it a watch
it's um as of the recording this I don't
know exactly what we're titling it which
is always subject to change anyway but
it's uh Rhett and Link in 1984. so we
subjected ourselves to all the
limitations of being in 1984 which is
the year that our friendship began
um
and uh yeah we decided that we wanted to
have the recess that we never got
because when we met you know our teacher
held Us in from the recess
but we so we we constructed this this
elaborate scheme to ex put ourselves
back in the 1984 of it all driving a car
from 1984 wearing clothes from 1984 only
speaking to people who lived in 1984 and
only using technological
accoutrement that was available in 1984.
specifically Maps
of the paper variety it was mostly about
the maps
it was a lot about the maps it was also
because we had to navigate across town
there's also a music video in there and
the song featured is on your streaming
services
LimeWire Napster if you want to burn a
CD of that you can do it actually if you
want to buy the single yeah yeah yeah
yeah so before the internet we had
something called singles and if yeah I
never never bought one I've very rarely
bought a single
um you can get that at mythical.com it's
um uh you are here his name is a song it
explores um
paper maps the conceit of the video and
musical form and also
male friendships which is another
discussion for another time like next
episode maybe next episode
um I'm very yeah I'm very happy with you
check out check out the 1984 video on
the rent link Channel please comment
share it with people
um
I love this song
uh I'm very happy with the video very
happy with the song
getting to do a little genre specific
yeah uh songwriting I'm enjoying that
part of of uh of the Renaissance
bringing it back
going back to the to the to the OG roots
and and
writing these songs we were just working
on a song Yesterday for the next thing
oh yeah is it the next thing is it the
next one or the one after the no it's
the next it's the next one it's the next
one okay the fourth one so
check that out but yeah so we're in like
this um pre-internet frame of mind let's
let me tell you it's just the struggle
is real when it comes to using paper
maps if you're Rusty on that and I don't
know any reason why you wouldn't be
um
yeah just watch that video before you
decide to let you know what things are
better
things were better you talk about going
one way and coming another way
um okay I mean we explored so much about
traffic and driving in the video that I
don't you know we don't have to talk
about that too much but sometimes
when you're looking on Google Maps and
you went one way to get somewhere
it it
if sometimes it just depends on which
direction you're facing
oh I'm on this side of the street and
now there's a couple of right you know
it's right people takes into account all
the right turns and all the left turns
and it can send you a totally different
way I drove an hour to uh Malibu
over this past weekend and went one way
went through Calabasas looking for some
rappers saw no one we had to get through
the gates and then once we got done with
all of our Malibus shopping and dining
and just having a good old time
apparently we're facing the other
direction and traffic had changed in
such a way it went back a totally
different way
that's that's one of the beauties of
Canon what'd you take which road did you
take uh we took um
no we took the one with uh Malibu Creek
State Park on the way there but then we
came all the way down to PCH on the way
back wow came through Santa Monica yeah
Scenic well they're both Scenic in
different ways
you know taking a long way home is
something you should do if it was my
wreck today I might recommend that but
there's nothing more thrilling than
you've got a better regular than that
then my map telling me to go the other
way back
I was talking about I was like I'm so
glad we're going this way and then it's
I also know that it's the quicker way
and also I don't like the other way
anymore because I've already gone that
way do you remember the first time that
you uh went back to North Carolina after
having grown up there and we knew all
the ways to like I guess at some point
there was a map involved but mostly it
was like okay if you lived in Bowie's
Creek
and you had to get to Lillington or you
had to get Lillington was easy because
it's just 421 but like let's say you had
to get to carry it you had to go to a
Waverly Place yeah because you had a hot
date
oh yeah for a movie
you knew how to get there because
you had driven with your parents and
your parents had been there multiple
times and then there was this transition
when you were 15 and your parents were
telling you where to turn right based on
the fact that they had memorized it and
then by the time you got your license at
16 you knew how to get there but it was
a it was very specific it was like these
turns and you had the different places
that you could go on a regular basis
when I went home the first time with I
guess it was
it may have been a GPS it might it could
have been my phone I can't remember
which one I know GPS I was using that
out here for when we first moved out
here before you used the phone
yeah but the first time I had a computer
telling me where to go to like get to
carry it sent me a slightly different
way
yeah we weren't making the best choices
nope every single time
we we were making the same exact choices
of how we were going to get to us to a
place and of course
traffic was something that you
encountered it wasn't something you
could anticipate or plan for it was like
oh well turns out there's a there's a
combine on this route today yeah and
that was just something you had to deal
with you ever recall being learning that
there's a different way to get to
Waverly Place that was better than the
way that you had learned yeah I remember
I would go with other people and be like
oh they're going a different direction
everybody would have their way every
family and somehow you if you're riding
with another family you you could pick
up their way
um but oh I got a new I can't wait to
show my family the new way
yeah I cut I remember when I don't think
I could have done that cutting through
the Bojangles
cutting through at Fuquay that Bojangles
and then going back through where uh don
lived in that like Sunset Lake Sunset
Lake
I remember when I first discovered the
sunset Lake cut off
to get to carry that was nice that's a
good route and then but then this they
lowered the speed limit leaving fuke
away and that got frustrating I was like
maybe I need to go back to my old ways I
don't think I could have sold my dick on
a different family's way like if I if I
came home and I was like Hey Dad the
maddoxes can get to carry five minutes
faster well two minutes faster it must
be real like he would Avail I don't care
you know what I mean I don't I think he
was like this is the way we get to Kiri
We're Not Gonna Change it because the
Maddox just get there two minutes faster
and how would you even know that what
were you timing it with your stopwatch
son right you know he put me on the
defensive real fast oh yeah
there's no way I could have defend that
but now we don't have to have
everybody's family is equal now because
we're all using
to get where we go I think it has to be
more
uh apropos in LA but I'm guessing
anywhere there's some sort of pseudo
Metropolis
you you're starting to adopt this habit
of even if you know exactly where you're
going you put it in your your map you
put it in your ways or your Google Map
I do not use apple map
it's it's just not as good
sounds good yeah because it's going to
tell you the right way to go and then
it's going to tell you if something
changes
it's like you're having this active
relationship with the internet that's
constantly assessing whether you're
doing the the best thing you know that
makes me feel so good I was so lost
yeah I was so lost for song and I didn't
even know it maybe we'll get into this
but obviously uh I mean I'm not too
worried about it but
we have lost something but we may have
we may have lost something that we don't
really know getting lost and so we need
it
so
if if you're a kid
and you're you're born into the new
system and you and the way that you
think about getting somewhere is like
well we use GPS to get anywhere we don't
use any of our own Intuition or
landmarks or memorizing the terms or
whatever I mean eventually you just by
default you'll memorize things if you're
going the same way every single time
yeah
but obviously you're losing something
that you're some part of your brain that
exists so that you can navigate your
world you're not exercising it anymore
like we don't none of us exercise our
math brains very often I mean how many
people do
anything beyond like the 10 10 times 10
like right I haven't solved for X in
quite a while
um much less integrated and then
hopefully the world will continue on and
it won't end or you know all the Jeep
there won't be some like giant Sun flare
that ends up taking all the GPS out and
we have to suddenly become like
people who use maps again but if we do I
think we'll be fine my point I'm making
is that you should feel okay because you
did it you did it in the video I did it
in the video we got to where you got
there before I did we we can navigate
VIA map even maps that aren't even
current we can do that yeah I don't know
about our kids no there's no kids will
just we will find them spinning in a
circle somewhere so we got some
categories we're going to go through
um just to kind of jog our memory about
what life was like for us before the
internet and through all the there was a
bunch of strange transitions like even
you talk about GPS when we moved out
here 12 years ago
what we were buying dedicated GPS units
to go on the dash homtom Tom Tom or
other brand yeah or a Garmin yeah I
think we both had a TomTom I think we
got a deal
at Best Buy and it was um not as good
as what we have now I don't I think you
could pay a service and get it to
connect to like traffic but there's no
way I just remember the lady would say
take a left on the five towards
Sacramento
Sacramento Sacramento you didn't even
say you just you just said the word
Sacramento
yeah they fixed that eventually okay
we're gonna talk about a lot more I do
want to talk about my shirt this is the
good mothical morning
uh that's nice there's some hidden
things it's a black T-shirt uh we have
it in a black with a white graphic and
then we have it in cream with a brown
Graphics anyway we're giving you options
because that's what y'all want and uh
it's got a lot of hidden this is for the
like you know this and first of all I
mean this is for if you're a Super Fan
yes but if you're like the kind of fan
that doesn't want people to know that
you're a fan of things which I've relate
to
um this is a way to like subtly sort of
indicate your that's a cool shirt what
does it mean uh
nothing you know like you can just say
don't be ashamed of us or you can be
like oh it's an internet show called
Good Mythical Morning like you can do
that too you have options we're giving
you options just like Trent's dad gave
him options
get up and down his stairs right go to
mythical.com and get the good mothical
morning shirt in both of the colors and
in the sizes
earbiscus is supported by chime good
money habits are really important to
have but can be hard to maintain whether
you just scored your first job congrats
congrats or you're ready to take
finances more seriously congrats Now's
the Time to start a healthy Financial
Journey when you sign up for chime and
Link a qualifying direct deposit you get
access to benefits like getting paid up
to two days early and fee free overdraft
up to 200 and with chime there are no
monthly fees no minimum balance and
absolutely no deposit required to become
a member so sign up for a chime checking
account today to link your paycheck it
only takes two minutes and it does not
affect your credit score get started at
chime.com ear that's chime.com ear chime
is a financial technology company not a
bank banking services and debit card
provided by The Bancorp Bank n a or
stride Bank n a members FDIC Early
Access to direct deposit funds depend
Amazon payer spot me eligibility
requirements and overdraft limit Supply
cchime.com spot me earbiscus is brought
to you by betterhelp uh most weeks I
you know my time is filled with this job
that we have here this good old job uh
in my time at home as a husband as a
father yes and you can realize that most
of the week has passed
and I haven't taken any time
for me
and I can't be the best me
for everyone else in my life when that
is the case I feel that it's easy to get
caught up in doing things for others
especially as bosses husbands and
fathers like we are which can lead to
things like burnout and stress and
therapy can give you the tools to have
more balance in your life so you can
support yourself and support others at
the same time I believe in my therapy as
me time
um
it even when I don't know that I have
things to talk about
I end up having stuff to talk about
things to process to understand myself
better and to to to to put myself to to
enter back into the the game you know
it's like take a little me time in the
dug out then get back in the game you
know so if you're thinking of starting
therapy give better help a try it's
entirely online it's designed to be
convenient flexible and suited to your
schedule just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and switch therapists
anytime for no additional charge find
more balance with better help visit
betterhelp.com ear today to get 10 off
your first month that's better
h-e-l-p.com slash ear
[Music]
do you remember my phone number
um your current one of course not you're
oh of course I remember your old phone
number you want me to tell it to you
uh-huh 919
it wasn't nope it was an I10 mm-hmm well
I remember back when they started that
new area code 910 and I did
you were not 910 dude
910 was the newfangled area code but you
had it online are you saying that 919
was before 910 and absolutely back to
919. I thought there was another one
before 910.
yes 919.
you sure 910 was newer yes
it was a big moment in Harney County I
do remember that but I could have sworn
it wasn't 919 before it was 910. I was
not when I moved when Mom and I moved to
the new house we got a 910 number
910-893
2729 uh
oh oh you're talking no you're my old
number 919 hold on 893-2979
what did I say
it's not that
two seven you said the you you got the
oh yeah 2979 2979 and I
just remember that for the first time in
a long time which because I never dial
my own number
um and then when I moved I got a 910
number 910
eight nine three
yeah that's right
I got it and and when we move and but
yours is
919-893-5083 yeah because I had the same
you know forever I had a stable family
my parents stayed together we stayed in
one house I made it very easy for you to
remember my phone number 503. it was
literally do you remember that was my
parents phone number until they moved
like
uh uh hopefully they don't have that
phone number right
they probably didn't report their
numbers not uh do you remember our dorm
room number freshman year of college 24.
not the number to this oh no no
not a chance 919-515
that that means 515 means nothing to me
how do you remember our campus prefix
and then the second why did I need to
remember that
because to tell the ladies who are going
to call us you know hello can I speak to
the shorter one
I don't say I do I did not remember 515
at all
five one five ninety one eighty two or
something I don't know can't I can't
quite remember okay so as we were
demonstrating uh yeah like
you knew everyone's phone number that
you had to call and I guess at some
point
someone had looked it up
mostly it was probably just like what's
your phone number and they wrote it down
and then you just memorized it but you
associate it it's crazy and of course
you only had to memorize really the last
four digits because
you didn't even have to dial the area
code right it was just
you know 893 and then those four digits
so somewhere in your brain you had this
spreadsheet Rolodex that had a family
or person within that family associated
with a four digit number and that isn't
something that happens anymore that's a
part of our brain that we don't use
anymore and like do you ever sit down
with your kids
and make sure that they
memorize memorize your phone number well
Lando's 13 and we were having a
conversation last week about it somehow
he brought it up he was like trying he
he was struggling to remember my number
but then he did remember it well yours
is easy to remember
phone number to remember of anyone that
I know yeah because I knew somebody who
worked for Nextel in 1996.
No 19 they give you a Primo number man
it was 2001 when I got my cell phone
2000 2001. yep
um but so so okay what did he say did he
remember it did you know your number he
remembered it yeah because where his
phone dies right and then he's got to
like go up and first of all talk to a
stranger to ask them to use the phone
like is that it could you even do that
like have you ever had to ask a stranger
to use their cell phone to make a call
uh no but my mom did when I was late
picking her up at the airport and her
phone died remember that oh I'm so glad
you have a good number
because what if like I changed my number
at some point when I changed uh when you
got service providers no I it wasn't
because of that I changed my number when
I changed service providers and I had
the option to Port the number over but I
but I saw an opportunity
having the same number since the year
2000 as I did
uh let's just say
there are a lot of people who have my
phone number and I didn't and I was like
this is an opportunity to reset who has
my phone number now I still have that
phone number that forwards to a Google
number so if you call me or text me on
that I can see but then I can kind of
make a choice if I want to interact
because that's technically not my number
anymore I mean when you start talking
about this in in pre-internet it's just
like you didn't know where anybody was
if they weren't with you
and and if you if they didn't answer
their landline they could be anywhere
and if they were like a child of yours
like we know where our kids are because
of location services yeah we do right
I mean I mean I've got we've got uh and
Chris like I don't I can look at Christy
can see where I'm at I can see where you
see the whole family it's so it's so
useful and gives you peace of mind right
especially as a as a parent or a loving
partner feels a it feels a little big
brothery I think for the well I mean
everybody knows that it's that it's
happening
but yeah there was there were times when
it was like well I'm just going to sit
around and maybe uh maybe maybe red will
call me back maybe he'll show up I'll
sit on my porch and see if he rides by
on his bike yeah on my bike I mean and
if you were late for something you were
just is he did he know about it did he
forget so you would wait for people you
would wait you would believe the best
but after a certain amount of time you'd
be like we're leaving there was a lot of
find out later what happened unknowns
like
I think my childhood would have been so
much better if my mom could have
communicated that yes I am going to pick
you up I'm just gonna be late like he
freaked me out so much as a kid yeah
yeah yeah that's that's the one for me
man is she gonna pick me up I always
thought she just wouldn't pick you up it
would just be late no she would always
pick me up but like she was always late
well you should have gotten used to that
I know but I suggested your schedule
this is like some sort of Peace of Mind
there man it's like oh well you know
once you once you're 12 or 13 you got to
have a cell phone you got to be totally
at all times connected to the internet
I feel a bit sorry for our kids in this
regard now obviously as a parent
I like to be able to immediately know
where both of my kids are and you know
I'm not that at this point I've got a a
19 year old that
you know I'm not he's still on the
family thing so I can see where he's at
but I'm not checking up on him 14 year
old okay you know depends on how late it
is whatever but we're not particularly
um
strict about this but we have Shepard
has friends whose parents are a little
bit more concerned about this
and literally just the other night
well in the morning Jesse and I looked
and we had a text from a mom of a kid
who had been hanging out with Shepard
and the text came at like 11 50 p.m we
were already in bed it was like a Friday
night but you know went to bed
and it was like I can see that the boys
are out roaming
as they're you know prone to do
and
you know what or when are they coming
back or whatever and we were like sorry
we got this after we went to bed which
is basically like where are you when
your kid comes to our house they are
doing whatever they want and we just go
to sleep they don't even have to be home
just so you know and the reason that I
do that why didn't she just call her kid
uh I think mate I don't know I don't
know uh but you probably did after you
didn't answer I think that
who's in charge here I've I've tried to
because our parents had zero idea where
we were so often
and many times we would tell them one
thing and do a slightly related thing
that wasn't exactly what we told them to
do that was pivot that was just kind of
how you know it's just a little pivot
um I kind of want my kids to have that
there's no autonomy have that freedom to
feel like there is no tether right but
there is there's a digital tether yeah
is it safer of course is it better
I don't know
I mean how did you answer the phone at
your house if somebody called I I wanted
to hear your answer to this
um at my house I would say hello
hello
you say it three times no no I'm just
trying to get the tone right if I was at
uh Nana's house I was told I was taught
to say new residents right and every
family I think because I had a mode I
didn't live there and if I people would
think that if a kid answered the phone
and there's no kid in the house that
like they have the wrong number
so I said Neil residents there when I
was at your house I was like
I would just pick it up and just hang it
right back up
yeah we didn't have a residence
again Neil residents very professional I
thought the way that I remember thinking
about this is that the rich families
always said
the residents and I and I remember
thinking I don't think we're rich enough
to say they call this a residence yeah
it's like I just remember thinking like
I don't I think those people in Keith
Hills like if you call a house in
Keithville yeah
that's a residence yeah they resided
jubi residents you know right yeah
Maddox residence that felt appropriate
but McLaughlin residence we just it was
like hello
you know hello
can I speak to one of your parents
either one will do
you know but most of the when you called
somebody
okay so could you um
I'm calling the phone could you answer
like I'm calling Michael juby okay and
jubi residents
custody to Michael
no no no no no is Michael there
yeah he's here is this Rhett that's
typically what they would say yes
hold on a second Michael calm down up
phone it's not in your pocket that
doesn't exist yet
and we're not putting one in your room
yet
get in here
exactly so that's exactly how it would
go but the thing that I didn't do
is I didn't say hello Mr juby it's Rhett
how you doing it's Michael here I just
said it's Michael though like I wouldn't
it's right I had no etiquette is that
what you would have done yeah yeah
that's what I know that's what I did
I mean you had to talk to parents a lot
but then when you showed up at
somebody's house don't even get me
started with the girlfriends we had a
neighbor I'm not gonna name names we had
a neighbor
who would because you would go to
somebody's house you would knock on the
door their parents would come to the
door and you would say is Michael there
you know that's what I would do and uh
when we had a neighbor
who would come to our door he'd ring the
doorbell
my mom or dad would open the door and he
wouldn't say anything you just like
stand there because it was like you know
you know why I'm here I'm not here for
you
and she would know what and my mom would
say when someone saw comes to the door
he just doesn't say anything and so I
will say
do you want to know if Rhett's here
yeah they know like nodding but well
he's not
and he just turns around and walks away
and then and she wouldn't know where you
were either man I don't have any idea
where he's at we haven't seen him in 48
hours
D now that now that you got the internet
you got these cellular telephones you
can you can be late to things because
you can just be in constant
communication about it it gives you an
excuse to be a little late let's be
honest I'm running 15 late
but I'm on the way you know even a
restaurant you know I've caught we're on
our way to restaurants oh man we're
calling restaurants oh we're we're gonna
be there I promise don't don't give away
our table I'd say we call restaurants
letting them know we're not going to be
there on time 40 of the time but it's
usually within the like 20 minute window
like if it goes beyond 15 you got a call
got a call you gotta call because
they'll just give that table to somebody
else what about information in general
you know it's like there was all this
talk as the internet was becoming the
Advent oh it's the information age
it is and I think it's of course it
still is I think that for me it's like
this is probably the it's like taking
information this is the biggest aspect
of what I feel it I mean everything is
different in the way that we're talking
about it
but if you wanted to know something when
we were kids
you would ask an adult and that adult
also knew nothing
you know what I'm saying it's like they
they didn't have the internet either
right there was some adults who knew
some things
but if you were like what's the capital
of Delaware
right but what are the chances that
somebody you know knows that if you're
not in Delaware you know what I mean
like I can't tell you right now and we
did it on GMM recently I don't remember
either because
sorry to the people of Delaware are you
I'm sure it's beautiful
I'm sure it's a beautiful capital
I'm sure you do lots of Delaware I'm
sure it's very important
we did not know it from that location
and you may not even know the capital of
North Carolina what is Raleigh okay
Charlotte it's not Charlotte it's
Raleigh
um so but here's the thing all the
information was available
in books so it was available in
encyclopedias yeah it was available in
the library but as I was thinking about
this I realized
never once not one time that I can
remember
did I ever have a question about
something
and then open the encyclopedia or go to
the library to get the answer never not
once I only use them yeah if I had a
book report right if you had an
assignment never never we were just
happy with not knowing stuff we didn't
know well you know it's like somebody
said and it but you would if somebody if
Uncle Bobby said something about you
know or the capital of Delaware is Saint
Paul not that
that's Minnesota yeah I know but you
would be thinking well it's like that's
Pro that's good enough yeah yeah why
would you question why am I going to
make that up I'm gonna walk some I'm
gonna walk to a bookshelf and crack open
a book yeah
no why you wouldn't do that
encyclopedias were cool though man for
the pictures yes yeah for the pictures
and just like sometimes it would be like
I'm going to read the encyclopedia for
fun I'm going to give you an idea of
what we didn't have going on right
well actually it's like I'm gonna get uh
Q didn't have its own
because Q is not in there's not enough
stuff that starts with Q so I think it's
like QRS
or maybe
what comes before QP maybe P Q was like
it was alphabetical is what I'm getting
at if you don't know what I'm talking
about
every single book I mean the fact that
had alphabetical things the fact that
the encyclopedias
we're supposed to contain all knowledge
yet Q still had to share a book
isn't that crazy and it wasn't you're
telling me that there ain't enough cues
related stuff for his own book in the
book that had to have everything and
think about this
Q sucks no one in their right mind who
was building a database right now is
organizing it yeah sure you can sort it
alphabetically
but no one sorts information
alphabetically because that's not how
the human mind works the human mind
works in category
so it doesn't so in alphabetical order
when you're thinking about something
just think about it for a second so you
would see like I'm gonna learn about
let's not use Q because it's too hard to
come up with words I'm gonna learn about
if I'm in the Seas it's like Canada and
then right after Canada is cans
I hope it's the other way around I think
no Canada because c-a-n-a and then cans
would be c-a-n-s so it would be the next
thing
we don't even know how to do
alphabetical order anymore Canada comes
before cans oh with an S yeah
but you don't they don't you don't look
up the plural version okay can comes
before Canada and then also in between
well and then and then after Canada
comes Canada well no with a z no in
France
c-a-n-n-e-s and so you'd be like I'm
gonna learn about
what a can is
and then I'm going to learn about the
country of Canada yeah and then I'm
going to learn about a city in France
that's my afternoon what do those things
have in common besides being CA starting
with c-a-n like that's not how people's
brains work and we that's the best that
we had now the Dewey Decimal System in
the library that was awesome that was
much better that was so good it was
organized by concept and like theme but
then it within the themes in the
concepts was alphabetical because how
else the hell are you going to do it why
the hell speaking of hell would you
start to put math into like
something that's not math related why
are you going to add a decimal
to like a group of organization that has
nothing to do with math
putting decimals in words
things were desperate back then I
actually I I think the Dewey Decimal
System
pretty great I I don't want to really I
don't know nobody goes to the library
what do people their libraries still
exist are are new libraries being built
why why how
well we went to the library at NC State
and it's awesome and it has a robot that
gets the book but it's hard to not think
yeah this robot is getting this book
this feels like a very temporary and
unnecessary step because that robot
could just be a computer without an arm
and could retrieve this information not
from a physical book
oh you're talking about a laptop yeah
exactly I think people go to the
libraries now
to
force themselves to study I think it's
just first of all it is a study
environment for sure it's got you get
it's the vibe it's like I'm here to
learn
I can't do this next to my bed
yeah psychologically libraries are
important practically they're useless no
what no all right Jenna is Jenna loves
the library we're pushing our buttons
defend libraries I don't know it's like
libraries are are a great resource for
people who can't afford certain things
like there's a library close by that has
like a sound booth you can go and record
there's also a library that you could
check out like a 3D printer and print
things off and you can go to libraries
for free classes on how to speak English
you're not describing a library that's a
that's a library that libraries do all
these things you can always check out
you can also check out um uh uh national
park passes at libraries if you so you
don't have to pay to go to a national
park there's so many great free services
about libraries and they're fully
underfunded by the governor
I believe in everything you just said
Thank You libraries are more expansive
we were talking simply about the books
also
they have computers and not everybody
has a computer so it is a way for people
to go on the internet I think that's
great but I did I would just call it
something else well that's tough we got
to put change the signage uh we can't do
that yeah that's true let's just change
what libraries mean slowly uh but I do
think not to get serious
uh
this
being
um having access to all this information
again does it make is it better or is it
worse like it I'm not making a judgment
about what's better and what's worse but
I do know that you know there's a lots
of pontification
about what's causing
uh the deconstruction movement which
when I talk about the deconstruction
movement I'm talking about people
deconstructing their traditional Faith
that's not just happening within
Evangelical Christianity our background
is happening all over the world people
are deconstructing traditional belief
systems
um
to be a person who did that in the 80s
again when you couldn't ask your dad
what the capital of Delaware was and
unless he like was from there
um if you ask an adult in your life a a
deep question about the nature of
existence well if you were in North
Carolina in the 80s you most likely were
going to whether you asked a person who
was from your church or went to church
or not they were going to kind of say
the same thing like philosophically
everybody was like well this is right
rooted in a judeo-christian world view
it's like God created the Earth and like
you know there's a couple of things you
got to do maybe it's do good things
maybe except whatever to get to heaven
people had different takes on it
but you never thought maybe that's not
true
because why would you think maybe that's
not true everyone else thinks this like
it's just part of the fabric of your
culture and your Society very and it was
pretty Regional I mean I remember for me
it was during a uh one of the most
significant like stages in my initial
reevaluating reevaluating things uh
was having a bunch of time at work on in
my first engineering job having a bunch
of time on the internet because
all our projects were getting shut down
because of the whole Enron thing that
was happening okay so I was supposed to
be reading manuals but I was going on
the internet to just research things and
I'm mostly just fun things like Crow
hunting or ultralights and all those
stages that we talk about yeah but I
also was interested in Bible stuff and
then I would and I was going to bolster
things I was like I want to like be able
to defend this thing I've got this you
know people are asking this question I
want to be able to defend it
but then very quickly I just found
myself getting exposed to these
different perspectives all Christian but
like different
perspectives like oh this this guy is
like thinks that there is there are
things in the Bible that are not true
you know or like it's not inerrant uh
it's it's infallible but it's not
inerrant and all of a sudden that's some
that's something I would have never
found in a library book I would have I
mean yeah sure it's in there somewhere
but why am I gonna look it up and so
right
to me that is people are like it's this
video games there's this or that the
reason people are deconstructing
traditional beliefs is because they have
access to a bunch of information I'm not
making even making a judgment on whether
traditional beliefs are right or wrong
I'm just saying that if people get
exposed to other perspectives in
critical perspectives on the things that
they were told when they were kids a
certain percentage of them are going to
leave those traditional beliefs behind
it's inevitable regardless of the truth
claims
and um
that's a it's a as a parent now first of
all I don't have a dogmatic worldview
that I'm passing on to my kids it's like
you have to believe this mostly it's
like hey like
we want you to be a loving person and
there's a whole lot of stuff we don't
know about and we we trust you and we're
you know
we'll figure it out together
it's a very different
system right but also if I started
talking to my kids about something
they already know about it and many many
times but also if I say something they
can immediately go and figure out well
what does somebody think about what dad
just said what do what does the internet
think about this
you know what I'm saying it just parents
don't have the same level of authority
when it comes to information because
that was the only place you could go
yeah if you wanted to know something you
asked the adults in your life and the
adult that you were around the most was
your parents and now
you're like I know my dad or my mom
doesn't know as much as the internet
does about this thing so that's a that's
a shift that we
we live through yeah like like the level
of critical thinking has gone up because
the ease with which you can check things
and know things well you just said the
level of critical thinking has gone up
which maybe has gone down let's think
about it well critical thinking is your
ability to to like think through
something logically I don't know if
that's gone up well I think that it
froze to other perspectives like being
I think we were okay with not knowing
things it's like we
we were had to be comfortable with not
knowing where people were not knowing
what the capital of things were or not
being totally certain about things so
like
because there was this there is a
just a baseline expectation that
something you you can get to the bottom
of something
yeah yeah I think so I I think that does
make I don't know if that makes you a
more critical thinker but it makes you
more critical yeah I agree with that I
mean
I haven't studied this but I don't I
think that people are not we have we
have we know more we have access to more
information but because you can kind of
just get it through a search
I think the critical thinking is like
one of the biggest issues right now it's
like lack of critical thinking I mean
it's not like it's ever been great like
across all of society or whatever but I
don't know I'm not I'm not so sure with
so much information it's certainly more
important to figure out how to be a
critical thinker because you got a
source it's more important than ever
yeah
um you know you were talking about
being in that engineering job and just
having access to all the information and
I said oh now I can learn about this now
I can learn about that for me that was
um there was like the music aspect of it
that was learning about music well
having it at your fingertips with you
know I was talking about Napster and
LimeWire like illegally downloading of
course the music industry had to catch
up but it was such an exciting time I
didn't have a personal computer or a
laptop until I started working
at IBM in 2000 like other than that like
some like yeah I didn't we didn't
scared a computer apartment uh uh senior
year senior year Dell computer the uh we
would go to computer labs and use those
for school work
um
and then you could I guess you could
download music I didn't take the time to
download and then burn CDs
like there were there was talk about
being illegal and I didn't know about
that but then like at IBM I would start
downloading music and listening to it on
like Winamp
just to have something to listen to
while I'm working you is and you're
doing this on company time and Company
computer oh yeah yeah that's trouble you
could have been taken to jail well
before that though but it was before
that the we we did not have
we talked a little bit about this as we
were putting together the the single we
were just talking about the level of
the amount of music that you had in your
home right it it consisted of your
parents record collection I don't know
about you but like you know my parents
being born in the 40s you know being
teenagers my mom had records going to
college in the 60s
they had a bunch of Records
and
my mom bought a lot of tapes I I took a
bunch of those records and I took the
ones that I wanted
put them in my room and I had my record
player and so I had that and then and so
and eventually like you had your nicer
stereo that had like a turntable on top
of it and then double double cassette
and then two speakers like if you know
you had arrived as a kid if there was a
dresser
in your room that and on top of that
dresser was a stereo with with separate
speakers and it had Equalization it had
equality yeah these little there's
little Equalization knobs or yeah you
know
switches whatever you call this and
I could play my parents records I could
play the cassettes that I was buying but
the frequency that I bought new tapes
was
one every two months
for me yeah yeah it was about the same
five or six albums a year right and of
course so the main mechanism of
Discovery is just listening to the radio
it was just so narrow and you would
record
because you had that fancy uh cassette
deal you could record the radio yep so
you would listen to the radio and then
when your song that you wanted now first
of all you might know okay they're doing
the countdown tonight and I know that
Billy Joel's We Didn't Start the Fire
which I didn't need to record that
because I had the album
uh right if Billy Joel did it I was
there for it
and uh you recorded it and you were like
oh man the DJ talked right up until he
sang because some DJs would be like I'm
going to say a couple of things as the
song's coming in here we go we've got
Billy Joel's We Didn't Start the Fire
and then it's like
whatever he would say right right on the
right right on top of it and then you
would perpetuate that in like your
mixtape so then like this DJ's intro
it now becomes part of it and the
Fidelity of the music yeah first of all
we were on cassettes so it's like the
worst medium
yeah in recent history
for audio quality but then add to that
that you're getting this FM signal that
doesn't have you know it's got static it
depends on what station you're listening
to like it's not perfect but that was it
and it was so precious it the the the
choices you you made about this were so
precious and you had to pay for every
single thing
and then for me the big the weird little
transition that took place while we were
in college before the stage that you
just described of downloading music
was BMG and the other one
that was just like BMG yeah so
Jen I don't know 10 CDs for this for a
cent do you remember the BMG catalog
that you would get CDs that you would
you too young for that
um that was like a 90s you would you pay
a Cent and they would they you would
send me like 12 CDs that you picked from
a catalog and and sometimes it would be
stamps and you would each each little
stamp would be an album and you would
rip out the ones that you wanted and you
would you would select your 12 and you'd
like to stamp and you'd put it down
there like a check box almost like a
check box there was little check boxes
all down and then you would get CDs you
would get all this you get all these CDs
and then after that they would mail you
a CD in the genre of your channel it was
a subscription service you weren't
paying a cent you were paying a cent to
sign up for this thing and it was
incredibly difficult to cancel it was
like 7.99 a month or something like that
and they would send you very difficult
to send you a CD and then you could send
it back
and get a refund or get a different one
I think you could exchange it but no one
ever did yeah my parents want to put up
with that they wouldn't they wouldn't
have let me do that yeah so we did so
our parents didn't do it we did it in
college well I would do the 12 and then
I would I would cancel I figured out how
to cancel yeah yeah yeah I can't do that
for sure I remember being
um
presented with okay you get to pick 12.
and and up until that point
I was on a five to six albums a year
clip up for my entire life yeah and then
suddenly to be presented with
12 albums yeah
I got I ran out of options like I got to
like number six and I was like well I've
got everything I want right because I've
got everything that I know from this
list and then well I'll get this
greatest hits from Kansas right you
ended up forcing yourself I remember
because growing up in Bowie's Creek it's
like just in the wind's pretty good man
you listen to country and we listen to
rap we weren't really in a rock
but I remember seeing Bob Marley and I
was like I've heard that name
yeah never have no idea what kind of
music this is good where when would I
have heard it when would I have heard
reggae
I didn't know what reggae was
reggae I can't even say it right reggae
and so what she's reggae I remember
getting that and this being like this is
incredible oh yeah and I'd forgotten
that I chose it because it was and you
would have to borrow it I would borrow
that one from you
and then I would you know I had a friend
freshman year in college who are like I
took about 18 CDs and like we would
start trading them and selling them to
each other
you know it's like the discovery
mechanisms were were so limiting and you
could record your CDs onto a cassette
and then right give somebody the
cassette a highly illegal but we did it
we made mixtapes
that was pretty that was important and
mixtapes were really important that was
never mixtapes were never like
like said to it wasn't cracked down on
no in any way no not like the an after
age people were made examples of like
these people would have like thousands
of songs on their hard drive on their
computer and then there was you know
there was like a federal sweep of
college kids getting arrested
you remember that oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah you hear about it happening in
other schools and at IBM I would be like
oh Lionel Richie has all these songs
that I didn't know about
because they weren't on the two albums
that my mom owned yeah
and I so all of a sudden this world just
opened up to me and it was like amazing
yet it was all like pirated and a lot of
it would be strange
what strange versions
yeah yeah yeah and one of the things I
think that this did
is once things became so ubiquitous and
you can listen to anything you want from
anyone also it's much easier to make
music and distribute it on the same
platforms
and we won't even talk about AI music
which is another huge shift that's a
different thing it's but it affects this
what I'm talking about is
everything with every iteration it
becomes less special
because it becomes less rare and
precious
and we just associate and so I think one
of the things
the way that we perceived celebrity
culture because I want to talk a little
bit about TV and movies
but the distance between us
and anyone who did entertainment that we
consumed
was a vast Gulf
unfathomable distance between us and
Lionel Richie still is
can't get them on the show apparently
um but
there were so few people who were able
to do it in a way that you would end up
knowing about because if we could only
consume so much
I
I don't that's a really mind-blowing
thing to me because it also impacts when
you think about visual entertainment and
obviously now if you want to make a show
you can also do it with the camera yes
there's like Gatekeepers or whatever but
like the the the lines between TV and
streaming or whatever like everything is
blurred
I remember
you've heard this but I had a cousin
who ended up being in a Oscar Meyer
commercial okay
and I don't remember this
um
I had met him one time he was younger
than I was and he was in an Oscar Meyer
commercial where like the hot dog like
drops out of the bun in a dog eats it or
something okay it's like on TV like on
national TV
and I don't just he lived in Georgia uh
I didn't really know the family like it
was just like we had because I don't
remember and I made it one time like my
cousin has a first name I don't remember
what it is and I just remember my when
my mom said you know
uh bow is in a Oscar Meyer Wiener
commercial
the dog eats his wiener and I had to
sit with that I I want you to I want you
to understand how much I had to sit you
had to sit with that
you had to take a seat it changed
everything for me what you see you've
forgotten
you have you you look it's crossed over
you look at me with this incredulity or
whatever the word is
um but you would have thought the same
thing
to know that you were related to someone
who was in a commercial
changed everything
and I just remember this sitting there
thinking about like he was you know he's
on TV like
he had here to like sit there and do
this thing and now it's on TV and I can
see it while watching like deuce of
Hazard
like how like how you would see it
because you how did you do commercials
and obviously now it's like you probably
go to school with an influencer right
you've got you've got several at your
school probably somebody and so whatever
or like you're in a neighborhood and
like somebody's their library's full of
information somebody's mom taking naps
is doing that thing that we talked about
on GMM recently with the mixing of the
waters water talking it up and so and I
mean ultimately I think this is a good
thing I I I I think that understanding
that everyone's just a person is a good
thing but things entertainment has
gotten so much less special and the way
that we relate to it
um yeah it's created all kinds of
opportunities we wouldn't be here we
wouldn't have been talking right now no
one would care to listen to this because
they wouldn't know what was happening we
would not have a career we would be
doing whatever else so it's been good
for us it's created jobs and
opportunities and all this stuff but our
relationship to an individual piece of
content is because it's so disposable
I don't know man
change things I was trying to figure out
you know it's like what what has the
internet not touched
this morning I went to the dentist
thanks for noticing
did you have an issue just a cleaning
I'm just cleaning
and they had to sign up said please do
not be on your cell phone when you're in
here in your in the dentist chair and I
honored that and I just sat there and
thought about maybe the dentist chair is
the is the last final Bastion of
of internetless experience you know you
got to have a person getting in your
mouth how long did you sit there do
something 30 minutes how long did you
sit there oh before they were working on
me but when you could have been on your
phone seven minutes which was so it was
torture okay well what did you do what'd
you look at what's give me the scene
there was a
um there was a print of a painting of a
scene in France on the wall and then
there was a window next to it and I
isolated between looking out the window
and um looking at the France painting
and just
thinking about France
how much I miss the internet in that
moment my dentist has a TV
and on the TV
is pictures that he has taken
while traveling
okay and he takes pictures not like hey
here's me in front of the Taj Mahal he
just takes pictures of things and mostly
he likes to fancy himself as a nature
photog
really so it'd be like he obviously like
went on a safari and like he took a
picture of like two zebras
and it doesn't we're not talking about
how did you know that he's definitely a
dentist he's not a he's not a project
professional did he tell you these are
my photos you can tell oh okay okay
I've been there enough times and seen
enough to know
he takes pictures wherever he goes and
he puts him on it and let me tell you it
gives you something to talk about uh I'd
say in in uh if you sit there for five
minutes the slideshow
is going to repeat a few times
oh we don't have a whole I mean he's
giving you the best of the best
um and I kind of it sort of puts me in a
little bit of a daze
I don't think about anything at all I
just like zebras
dentists taking pictures of gazelle
Lions waterfall you know and uh so
that's what he does so it's a little
kind of I think he knows
because they have the same sign if we
sit these people in these chairs and we
don't give them something to look at
yeah we don't know what we're gonna have
on our hands
you know
yeah you get antsy of just not knowing
something
new something news going on
somebody might be talking to me
I might be able to conduct some sort of
a relationship through this
internet
right now well I mean it's also
there's an addiction there's an
addiction to it too it's like it's you
don't even think about it right if your
wife goes into the
um is like I'm going into this store
and you are not going into the store and
I am not and you're the guy who's
sitting on the bench yeah outside of the
store what are you gonna do just look
like a crazy person that looks like a
private eye who's like watching people
right you gotta be the only thing you
don't want to creep yeah a man sitting
on a bench not on his phone head up
looking around he's private eye that
dude is up to no good that guy is a part
of a larger operation you know what I'm
saying yeah yeah he's I'm on the lookout
might as well give him an earpiece right
right yeah you can't get away with that
you can't be sitting and looking this
actually makes me feel better about
constantly being on my phone but so I'm
not creeping you feel that little itch
you feel that little itch in your brain
and it doesn't have to be anything it
literally is
right it's information
that doesn't do anything to enrich your
life
and you also can't do anything about it
let's just be honest you find out the
latest thing that happened in the in the
the war on the uh the front in the
Ukraine war
um I'm not saying you shouldn't be
informed but what is you're sitting
outside a Cheesecake Factory and you
find out the latest thing that happened
what are you gonna do you're about to
eat a [__] cheesecake you're not
you're not gonna do anything with that
information what are you gonna do well
you're going to know it make a call to
zalinski and give him some advice no
you're not but you're gonna you're just
gonna eat cheesecake But You're Gonna
Know It
and then knowledge is but did you need
to know it right there I'm not saying
you shouldn't be informed
but shouldn't there just be like a
little time in the day like okay I want
to know what's going on in the world
yeah here it is
I keep trying to figure out like let's
try to go a day without the internet can
you try to do that I mean I'm not going
to turn that into a video that seems
like well I've tried to
I haven't succeeded
I've tried to
stop like no phone after 7 PM I did that
for like what about like all day two
weeks well let's start with baby steps
man like not having the internet two
weeks seven o'clock
you put your phone somewhere
I put it like on a charger yeah but you
did but if you stream something that's
the internet you just try to get rid of
your phone I'm saying get rid of the
internet like you can't stream anything
yeah but streaming is like TV
but that's the internet yeah but what
what's this what what are you trying to
avoid at that point I'm not saying it's
not a good idea but it feels like a
different thing I'm trying to break the
habit of like give me I I know that give
me this thing this is an internet
conversation I'm trying to broaden it to
like you can't get away from it unless
you go to the dentist okay but like can
I watch a VHS yes what's the difference
well it doesn't use the internet I'm
just saying I'm being a stickler here
okay well I'm gonna name something
besides going to the dentist where
you're not gonna so you want me to like
maybe take a hike okay you want me to
play succession on my TV and record it
on my VCR I don't even know how to do
that anymore how would I even do that
but you have a VCR no exactly I have to
buy a VCR you couldn't have to hook it
up to my team if you were going a day
without the internet I can't even be you
couldn't you couldn't watch
entertainment you couldn't listen you
couldn't be entertained by
anything that you could watch or listen
to it all goes through this some people
have made this choice just just so you
know and there's no doubt they're
happier
No Doubt
I mean this whole idea of like
getting some information again
finding out
you know that
two celebrities that you don't know are
getting a divorce and finding that out
right before you go to bed
right you don't need to do that what
uh what am I gonna do with that now I'm
gonna dream about
Tom Brady and Gisele and and when I got
an opportunity that problems in their
relationship
what
that's my cheesecake digests right as my
perfectly curated meal of as much fat
and sugar
just move slowly through my digestive
system and I'm just dreaming about
Giselle
like it's just idiocracy man that's what
we're living in you know it you know it
that's what we're living in dude let's
just get outside let's touch some grass
they say
let's touch grass
um that's what we need to do today it's
not my wreck but that's my wreck well my
wreck is get a robe
what
and this is get a robe this is intended
for those of you
40 and above if you're under falafel in
Residence if you're under 40 you can
move along
uh I just gotta say if you're 40
and above you should have a robe
because listen I'm just gonna be honest
with you
I know there's a lot of you onesie folks
out there and I don't wanna I don't
wanna [__] on your little onesie parade
but really
you need to move on you're too sweaty
you need it first of all like you need
to move on from a onesie it's a four
it's for the 40 and under crowd it's
really technically for kids but we'll
give you like an additional 25 years so
the robe is the old man's onesie
a robe is all a onesie is all about
being comfortable and I'm just saying
but also being dressed up as an animal
usually
I I'm just saying that the robe is the
ultimate loungewear and but they come
open too easily no not if you get a good
one and are you recommending no
underwear nope I'm recommending whatever
you like
uh
uh I typically wear underwear under mine
because it's just like but nothing else
if you sit down and slippers are nice
too if you if you're like oh but the
onesies that make me feel good we'll get
wear some slippers
[Music]
I'm just saying you should have a robe
uh like you're going after the onesie
community no no you're more
sophisticated than that you are like you
you you you you you've there's seven to
you you graduated you graduated to a new
level 30 year olds don't wear onesies
dude yeah they do yeah they do yeah okay
Jenna yeah see yeah they do they do now
I've never been much of a onesie guy
because of you know they're not sized
properly and it feels like the Grand
Canyon is trying to make its way through
my crotch I'm gonna take your advice
though
I'm gonna I would have thought you've
already got robes yeah I just don't know
how to really use it
you don't wear your robe like
no
if I'm what so when I get home from work
am I just I stripped down into underwear
and put on a robe I'm not saying that
I'm not much of a can I call it a
smoking jacket even though no smoking
you can do it all you want to I I'm not
and if you want to do this it's totally
fine I'm not a uh
much I'm sure to
people's shock I'm not a get home and
change clothes change into something
more comfortable kind of guy I am you
know but it's not a robe so I'm I'm the
robe is a weekend thing for me okay
there are definitely Saturdays maybe
Sundays robe mode where nothing touches
me other than a robe
ah challenge accepted man uh I'm gonna
work on my robe mode and it's very
difficult to have an argument with
someone in a robe
if you see somebody in a onesie you want
to argue with them you kind of know that
they're probably wrong before you even
know what we're talking about you
talking about the grocery store have you
robed it to the grocery store I'm not
anything go go Lebowski no I have some
standards but I'm just saying that I'm
not saying that I get into a lot of
arguments but it would be difficult for
my wife to get too upset with me
if I was in a robe you look like I mean
you look like a loafer dude and it makes
it easy to get upset it makes you feel
make something of yourself you've been
in your robe all day well and it makes
you feel like
how many things could go wrong right now
like how many different situations could
I find myself in that would be
life-threatening or
there's in a robe well you could expose
yourself to the mailman right he's not
gonna kill me for that but also if
something does go wrong
you're very much not that likely to get
too concerned about it you know what I'm
saying it's like it's a statement oh
gosh somebody's arm just got almost
completely suffered and now I've got to
go to the emergency room
I'm in a robe though you know what I'm
saying it's like let's not rush
okay let's not let this upset the apple
car too much okay
maybe I need a new robe
I mean the only reason I started doing
excited about when we got that robe at
the YouTube Summit
which is a ridiculous robe by the way
yeah I mean first of all it says Good
Mythical Morning on it no and it's got
one side is candy cane and one side is
green and blue stripes first of all
don't judge me for wearing something for
that says Good Mythical Morning on it
that we got at a YouTube thing because
you wear that Giant hoodie that says
Good Mythical Morning on it and you wore
it at a party at your house with like
mixed company well I was cold yeah but I
mean I mean I I don't do that I'm not
gonna wear that robe outside of my
family I have four
whoa yeah yeah you got a rotation
yeah you have if you wear them as much
as me
that one's a terry cloth one yeah great
for drying off and then I got a thin one
and then I've got one that Jesse got me
another terry cloth one that's like a
white one that's like my backup
it looks a little too much like I'm
trying to go to a spa yeah because it's
all white but it's about the other two
are in the laundry I'm just saying you
should try it you should try if you're
over 40 do it it will make you feel
differently about everything I'm gonna
try it
of course join the conversation using
earbiscuits and leaving us a voicemail
responding to this or any other episode
1-88
earpod one next week we're gonna be
talking about
male relationships friendships
hey you written link this is Colton
I am calling you from the inside of the
IBM building 305
we are testing the audio
you might be able to hear the music but
I just remember hearing your podcast
about your engineering days and I
thought of you guys thought of you link
knowing that used to work out here
pretty cool I feel like I'm kind of
walking in your footsteps a little bit
so I just wanted to shout out tell you
guys I'm thinking about you guys and uh
hope you guys are having a great day and
uh yeah that's all I got
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
foreign
[Music]